from being in the community from being
involved in this project for years what
does it talk to you about people being
in this community in particular that was
so zero tolerant and I was too like I
believed in zero tolerance even when I
had my kids minute no certainly
understand what it meant and people say
to me how could no one have known you
know what was going on there you know
people even in the community said or
around the country they say probably how
could people not know that this is all
going on you know half the time there
wasn't lawyers in the courtroom and I
always say well there was always a
lawyer in the courtroom or prosecutors
there there were all sorts of people in
the courtroom the reason no one knew
what was going on we were all complacent
and complicit because we all believed in
zero tolerance we all thought you know
be tough on kids we were all fine with
it until we found out there was millions
of dollars involved and all of a sudden
we weren't fine with the way the kids
were being treated anymore you know to
me that's hypocrisy I get to say it
about my own community because I've
lived in the community and I think that
the community has to catch up to that
because when they blame a single person
for all that happened they don't realize
necessarily how unrealistic that really
is it takes a village to raise a child
it takes a village to destroy a child as
well and I think that's a realization
that my community is coming to grips
with now and I think that more
communities around the country as they
see the film will come to grips with as
well and you hope that others will
become more empathetic I think you
mentioned that you know you would see a
kid maybe and think well that's a bad
quote bad kid and as any parent would
they would want quote a bad kid to stay
away from their kids but I think you you
said that it made you soften a little
bit and open your eyes to people's
situations a little more it did and i
think i have i've always had some
empathy but I used to judge people much
more harshly adults and kids before this
project i just did I'd see somebody and
I'd sort of to make a judgement man I
tell you it's my whole automatic filters
have changed completely because of the
project I literally no longer look at
people that way and the thing about you
know zero tolerance is that it's black
and white and in this world there is no
such thing as zero tolerance as far as
mechanical things you know there's
tolerance within a certain level of
tolerance
and zero tolerance means does it like
why are we doing it to kids or people
and i think that the zero tolerance idea
is I want zero tolerance for your kid
not mine because if my kid does
something wrong see I know my kid I know
where its intentions but it's your kid
that I worry about and when a kid is
labeled a juvenile delinquent no other
parent wants that kid to hang out with
their kid because you know they're bad
they're a bad kid we've had people that
have seen the film and pre-release that
have contacted us one way or the other
and said they they they'll never look at
a kid the same way again which i think
is great and the fact that you know
they're not they'll be less suspicious
now because we've created the suspicion
about Oh kids are evil and I'm going to
do bad things and I think that that'll I
think that's going to change I really do
I believe it's going to change it if
people enough people see the film what's
your take on this new label of affluenza
making a child behave a certain way
versus how the court system seemed to
view some of these families with their
own bias thinking that oh well maybe he
came from a quote troubled home I think
we all come from troubled homes in a way
I mean I you know show me a family that
doesn't have some level dysfunction
that's the problem we label kids at risk
I think all kids are risk and I think
that schools who contribute more kids
into the juvenile system since Columbine
then any other time ever in Pennsylvania
alone had a three hundred percent
increase in placing kids into the system
since Columbine three hundred percent
yet juvenile crime has been coming down
way before column line continues to come
down III think that we have sort of lost
our way in the way that we look at kids
and I think we need to kind of pull
ourselves back and realize the kids are
kids and like kids live their lives and
learn from mistakes they make just like
we did when we were growing up
you